hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to darkwood
in what maybe the last episode
i have no idea i i there's a whole old
woods still to explore so i'm
beginning to think that maybe no but
whoa
what the hell can i throw a flare into
that
no i wanted you to throw it okay that
worked apparently
uh sure i need a key for this
door can i bash it i can
hello a fire axe and an odd stone
all my mushrooms a hunting rifle wait is
that what the dude gave me
all right i'll save the fire ex for a
little later is there anything under
this
okay i often forget that i can just bash
things open
probably a really easy way to do things
i don't need more rope
why are they giving me more stuff if i
if this is the it's be
there's got to be something going on
here there's got to be something going
on
bear trap oh sorry that might have been
a bit noisy
what moaning
interesting well these can all just go
hello hi
it's your boy oh good
a plain countryside bed metal buckles of
leather straps fastened to the bottom of
the bed are twisted and broken
okay good hey
you know if the doctor had the key why
didn't he just try to leave through the
door then
where where's the doctor where's the
well at all mommy daddy went out and
left
i angry and was hungry was he
i'm hungry too can't move head is
exploding and if i move i'll burst
myself
okay good have you seem to be moving but
good luck
oh partial decomposed corpse left hands
bitten off together with the arm
well that doesn't bode well for what's
out here you know
they really don't bode well you know i'm
going to put the uh
i'm i don't know if i'm going to use it
but i'm going to put the hunting rifle
on the uh yield hot bar so that i can
have it ready oh is that the house
it's the house isn't it oh my god it is
that's where it's
i'm gonna leave that i don't need a damn
thing in that
crate i don't need a damn thing
[Music]
generator switch on why not right why
not what's around the back of the house
eh
what's around the back of the house eh
might as well just keep this on
oh is that that dude that i killed
trying to get out of here
i know him oh i know him all right
anything over here no okay
i'm gonna hop in
an odd stone okay got it
better than a shiny stone well not as
valuable apparently so
i'm not gonna repair that wait
the layout is different when you look at
it versus not that's bizarre
safe oh there's stuff in the safe which
is weird
so weird it's like the um the shadow
version is my memory of this place
and now it's it's been moved i mean
obviously this place has been broken
into
photo oh what am i looking at
what am i looking at what one for 1206
85 what am i looking at is that a person
is that a statue is this a tree
i don't know what i'm looking at
homemade device for producing moonshine
it's super disorienting just trying to
look at this and try to keep it all
together because of the way it changes
in the shadows poor dog
ah sign finally some good food
safe locked with a code i don't remember
what the i don't think i ever had the
code for this
i don't i don't know i don't know any of
the codes that's the thing about this
game
there's so many things with codes that i
have no idea what they are how am i
supposed to know
what all it is about if i can't ever get
a code
because there are tons of places with
codes and i have yet to find
one except that came through the
freaking radio
yes i gotta go through the narrow path
from whence he found me
the trees blocked the way ahead sure
about that
yes they do yes you yep you're sure yeah
you're sure about that
the trees just kind of conglomerate into
one wall of tree it's very weird
okay so what am i supposed to do
well there's not really a way to go yeah
it's just kind of turned into all
tree all the time so what do i do about
that
so what do i do well what do i do
why did you bring me here
wait four oh wait in the room four
nine wait wait are there other numbers
that's sneaky
i almost wouldn't have noticed that
eight eight eight
four nine eight four nine eight i mean i
could brute force it from there
if if that's in in order if it's not in
order then it's a completely different
beast
the lines wait the lines the lines
oh oh my god the lines
the lines there'll be another number
under here oh
okay it must be nine five four eight
because it's leading there
nine five four eight eight
no okay fine other way around then eight
four five nine
oh code the code to the cart door 1814
1814 cart door
the train
the toy so i'm good
i can leave now right because i'm
getting out of here
my house burst in half
everything here just bursts hey
you here
kill me and take my house
my cracked hut okay
sorry i guess that was mercy
okay cracked home
bad stuff okay it looks like this might
not be the end
as i thought it seemed like there was
more left to go
i'm assuming i can just go back now
right
there i go where am i okay here
all right great it's 9-0-0 okay hey bud
looks like i'm hunting you now can't
smell me can you
oh god okay all right
okay all right here we go
oh god ah not this not now okay i'm
gonna switch to gun
i don't know where you are i don't know
where you are i don't know where you are
i don't know where you are
serpentine serpentine
wow okay god damn it okay goddammit
serpentine
server dean take it take the pill ah
god i'm gonna run i'm gonna run what
good move good move good move me i'm
gonna get you
ow
oh my god really
huh you guys are too much effort for
you give nothing but that meat
well if the birds were there surely you
can't blow up
there's no way right
i was right oh my god did i leave the
genera oh my god oh my god
why are the wait pig heads why are there
were there always pickets there okay i'm
back
let's go ahead and repair the you know
actually what kind of upgrade could we
do to this
oh my goodness yes
i have an axe head i forgot about that i
have one
i'll get the sharpened one later i don't
have rocks
which is weird i know but i don't have
rocks it's fine
and i'm gonna make some more armor we're
gonna hold off on the hunting rifle just
for the time being this will do good let
me get used to the
okay it's an overhead it's still as much
of a wind up a little quicker than the
shovel
definitely a little quicker all right i
just gotta go find some rocks
and that's fine i'm gonna go over to the
church and see what's up there
okay church this is the church this is
the steeple
oh my god where are all the people they
wouldn't have put bear traps in the um
in the church would they
i don't know so many candles so many
flowers so many candles so many flowers
a red one a green one for my little
girls coward
thief what go under the floor where you
belong i
yeah i'm okay i don't have to go eight
eight four eight all right you know if
he's just gonna give it to me
and kiss them for me
not 100 ooh shovel blade thank you not
that i need it
electronic game wow
that's great hello
thank you all right i'll go under the
floor now
i don't trust this i don't like this i
don't want this
oh no um
where's my wood oh god no
i didn't mean to go out but maybe that
would be for the best i am
poisoned okay back into the abyss
great yeah i love this place
wish i brought the bandages do i have
like the poison thing
nope just more pills okay let's just
assume everything blows up in here
absolutely everything blows up
every little thing every big thing
every small thing blows up there's
mushies up there
are you an enemy can i make like
bandages or so i can't make anything i
dropped everything off
grandma pop another pill i don't trust
you
oh god oh god oh god
oh god oh god here we go
there we go and one more for action okay
that chomper good great that one will
can i have
the mushies thank you
got it you guys seen any rocks around
here i really could use some rocks
never thought i'd say that but you know
really seem to be short supply of rocks
do you think i could just go around pick
them up off the ground but apparently no
that's um
that's against the rules oh my god i'm
not gonna kiss
anyone down here i'm gonna kiss nobody
i don't know what that guy was saying
i'm not kissing nothing
oh what is that
hey oh my god oh i'm such an idiot of
course
okay one more one more yeah
one more yeah
one rag one rag twisted key yeah great
that'll work definitely touch the radio
yeah the radio
that was such a whoa oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god bang boom all right no
oh my god
give me the pill take the goddamn pill
dude you're your babies suck
i tried to kiss him they kiss hard
they kiss so intensely i'm not ready for
that kind of passion
turn on the radio i'm such an idiot i
guess i'll try again
i should just burn them i should just
burn them that's what i should do i got
molotovs why aren't i using them
yeah yeah yeah ow okay
yeah oh god oh that didn't work out well
okay this is not working out well for me
oh my god
i don't even know what time it is hi i'm
back hey i know you saw me go down there
and not come out but hey you know
just man those kisses i couldn't help it
i had to go back for seconds these
oh my god oh my god oh my god get the
gun out you witty
and i'm just gonna shoot i'm gonna shoot
that's what i'm gonna do
i'm gonna shoot bang boom
how owing and then one more
no you're good all right good
all right we're just gonna shoot him
that seems like a good idea
maybe i should have been doing that from
the get-go
oh
oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god
oh my god let me out i need to reload
i'm not used to the gun mechanics yet
gun mechanics are a little
oh where'd he go you were here
there you are you boink
got him my lantern's almost gone
that's what you get that is in fact
what you get uh you get what you deserve
okay my light is almost gonna go out god
damn it and then i'm gonna be
kind of boned oh wait was that
it oh was that it
oh that was it and i went back
and i shot him i assumed there was more
i assumed there was so much more hey my
landers out
good you know great you're not great
this is just fantastic
i love this hey thanks bud hey your your
your babies are
terrible horrible actually
i really hate them cannot overstate how
much i don't like those babies
okay let's go wait i gotta cook and then
we gotta
figure out what the hell we're gonna do
for tonight because i do not know
man it's gonna be a weird night
okay how about scream i like the idea of
scream i can just make him run away
because i scream real good
i scream really good so shouldn't be a
problem with that
what's the fever dream gonna be this
time i hope it's a nightmare land
filled with corpses and hate
oh oh it's
oh it's oh is that my wife
turn off the light you got it wife
i want to sleep some more okay good you
got it you got you got it
you you got it wife oh
it's too early to cook
i'll run myself a bath the frannia
washing machine
i spent two days in queue to get it
seems nice
seems really nice
an old trusty sofa my black and white tv
set
yay yay
hey let me eat a pear hello
hi who's there
hi oh it was the man in the hat
which is me i'm the man
in the hat i'm the hat man
what does that mean wait why did i have
the memory of someone that wasn't myself
what is the implication of that and why
don't i like it and i don't
like it i have so much stuff i never
thought that i'd be at a surplus of
stuff but i am
i'm gonna need another lantern that's
for sure oh i'm definitely going to want
to
build traps tonight but it's not quite
time to do that
shovelhead oh i guess i'll just trade
that up for that
well i guess i might as well put gas in
the generator right now
yeah who am i really that's the biggest
question who
am i that's the thing i always ask in
games is who am i
who is this person here what are they
doing what are their objectives
uh that might be enough for tonight i
don't know i have just a little bit of
time i'm gonna go
south very dork
dog try me
those are easier to dodge than the other
ones but still it's risky
getting better at it though
whoop dog god there's one rock was it
really that hard to find rock before am
i just
very dumb it might be very dumb because
i need to sharpen my axe but i need rock
to do it but i only need rock to do it
i could just find a few more
more than that but that's a start
got him okay well let's get back i'm one
rock
shy maybe in this pile here
yes yes yes
yes yes and you
yes yes dinner's ready
now this defense needs a lot more traps
is what i've
realized but first let me upgrade
my axe to be sharpened cool
straight blade sharpened that's good now
let me repair
cool okay i don't know what chain trap
is
let me try to do one just to see how
it works i don't know how it works turn
on the generator
okay so let's try the chain trap
i don't know what that means all right
let's rebuild this door
let's put this outside the door
so that i can open it up and kill what
gets trapped in here
no let's let's let's not put it there
because i have the chain trap there
let's put this here so i could maybe
run run a monster through there how much
time i got um
i think i need to put a little more gas
whoo almost just went in my own trap
like an idiot just gonna dump this whole
thing in
okay and then i'm gonna put the last
spare trap right here
and then let's button her up at a time
at a time at a time at a time
uh that'll have to do molotov just in
case
this the light there i don't have armor
that's okay
flares yes i have flares okay that'll
have to do
let's go ahead and just do this let's do
this okay i got my sharpened axe
at the will power i'm ready to rock
that gets caught in my trap what was
that oh my god it did
oh [ __ ] that was just a regular dog
that that was a waste of a trap then if
the banshee comes in i'm gonna burn in
it
i'm just burning it probably the best
trap honestly is just laying down gas
and then throwing a match at it honestly
that is probably a much more effective
trap
than anything i've had in the past
whoa oh my god it's a banshee okay five
yeah you light it light it throw it boom
burn
burn burn burn burn
did you burn oh my god babies burn burn
babies burn
i need my ah they're coming in oh my god
okay
all right wow wow wow wow why
well i'm gonna close that door now yeah
the whole gasoline thing
probably is a better idea
what is that what is that
what is that what is my eye pain yeah
pain
no joke pain what the hell
what is what is going on
what was that about wow why
my god what is the the pain ow
you are an a-hole
[Music]
dil weed are you gonna do it again yep
called that one
oh god no i will burn you i'll burn you
i will burn you i will burn you whatever
you are i will burn you
i will burn you
what are you what are you what are you
what are you
what are you what is that it's a banshee
i'm just gonna hide he doesn't know that
i'm here i can wait until dawn
no don't come here don't come over here
i will burn you i will burn you
i will burn you come on sunrise come on
rise
rise sunrise
[Music]
i've made it two weeks hey man
good to see you boy have i had a night
let me tell you
these nights are getting rough okay
that's gonna have to do
all right huh i'm i'm gonna start
employing the fire
and match technique i'm just gonna have
them in my inventory because
frankly i can see no reason why not to
it seems like that would be a very
effective
trap that it seems like that would kill
people very dead
so if i just do that then i don't have
to worry as much
about me being dead maybe i don't know
let's
giddy out of here we're gonna go explore
this west no we're gonna go to the train
that's right
it's time to go to the train no
pussyfooting around 1814. we got a code
who farted so apparently there's some
kind of a code for this
i'm not sure where though journal yeah
uh no with the code i found some code
i don't know what it's for but i hope it
opens the door to his current hideout
you
code code to the cart door i got a
twisted key too
looks more like a crowbar or whatever
says something about a cart
metal door
hello what what are you doing here
hey bud let me look at this photo real
quick
wow she's a beaut take this booze hey
you have my key yo you have my key buddy
don't run away from me
hey how you doing hi
you have my key i'd like to talk
i'd like to talk the doctor is lying
against the train's car wall his face is
covered in sweat an intense odor of
alcohol hangs in the air
do not come close i won't give you your
key can't you understand i saved your
life
you'd rot away in that clearing if it
wasn't for me you owe me for [ __ ] sake
doctor moved closer to the wall
grotesquely kicking his legs against the
floor
you think i don't know who you are rat
i've managed to get a good look at you
your kind visits us whenever you please
you hide behind the trees watch us from
a distance and then disappear
you have no idea how it is to live here
this place these woods
everything's [ __ ] up here i won't take
it anymore you understand
i won't bear the look of those deformed
wreaking bodies anymore
nor the cries of the wretched villagers
first they begged for help
now i need to hide from them i'm just an
ordinary doctor
how the [ __ ] was i supposed to help them
how the doctor goes silent his face now
hugging the wall of the train looks
truly pathetic can you hear it
in the walls they speak to me my little
girl is calling me
i know she's waiting for me i must come
back to her
she's so close his voice breaks down i
want to go back home
i can see panic in his eyes please this
key is my only chance
help me escape this place help me or
kill me
interesting okay so like the doctor's
done some [ __ ] up things
i think you don't look too good either i
mean honestly like
i don't see a reason to kill him but he
won't give me the key unless i kill him
we could go together maybe i don't know
i'll show him
i take out the map and show the doctor
the location of the abandoned house with
the hidden underground entrance the
doctor stares at the map for a long
while without lifting his gaze to meet
mine
thank you he removes his dirty glasses
with a trembling hand and freezes
i will wait for you there and better
take the essential things with you
looks like returning here will be
impossible oh
so we are going together we are i knew
it
i knew it hey you know it's okay
i'm okay with that i don't know who this
doctor is but that last memory seemed to
suggest that we we
had met because it looked like the
memory that i last had from the last
dose of mushy uh was from the
perspective of the doctor
and then i i was at their door or i was
at someone's door i don't know who
and then i probably ruined their day but
i'm not nearly ready
to go there there's still all of this
section that i haven't explored
because if we can't come back then i
need to make sure i have the best
equipment with me
because i mean he said it was some
finality and i left the freaking
generator on
there we go but that's all the time i
have for this episode this is
fascinating
so i have the option of following him
yet but i don't think i'm ready there's
a lot of open-ended actually let me see
what the journal entry just said for
that
found the doctor i've agreed to help him
escape the woods we are to meet by the
door inside the underground passage
i hope i won't regret it i hope i won't
either
but hey whatever the woods are nice it's
it's kind of nice
was he going to lock it behind me ha ha
no way anyway thank you everybody so
much for watching
and as always i will see you in the next
video
bye-bye
[Music]